друзі всім привіт ну що у нас дуже
важливі новини зі світу у світ
Транспортний блокує рашку дуже
хороші новини це те, що світ по
саме більше литва латвія та естонія
блокуючи транспортне сполучення з
росією та білоруссю я
записую цей блок з поїзда ось у
україні місця на все, що вони влаштували і
поїзди ходять і транспортне сполучення
є країна витримала удар, а ось раніше
схоже приходять не просто важкі
а зовсім тяжкий громадяни
активно останнім часом завозили фурами
через Білорусь через Прибалтику через
польшу до себе товари скоро це все
має закінчитися як повідомив Мустафа
наймемо заступника міністра
інфраструктури україни україна
звернулася до цих країн із проханням
закрити повністю повністю закрити
будь-яке переміщення автомобілів вантажних
через цю межу тобто повну
транспортна блокада та
за його даними протягом двох-трьох діб
це може статися взяти це буде дуже
важливо дуже значно більш серйозно
підірве і рашку ну і так під роздачу
потрапляє тут і білорусь яка
надала не білоруський народ
ясна річ подивіться мої відео з
білоруським добровольцем із батальйону
костусева Калинівського
які записав у бучі вчора вона є на
фейсбуці є на телеграмі
заходьте дивіться але лукашенко
надав територію Білорусі для
цього жаху звідти по нас стріляють
ракетами там візу снаряди до вбивць
звідти була атака на київ ця моторошна
середній у буча гостомель ірпінь та
тому Білорусь звичайно тут теж
потрапляє і в нього й інакше бути не може
ось
яка дійсно дуже важлива подія
сталося але й у світі після цієї різанини
теж у світ я скажу вам я такого
буквально
за ці кілька годин я увімкнувся
розповісти про цю різанину французькою
телебаченні на одному з провідних каналів на
бі-бі-сі на ще одному британському чупі
news на індійському телеканалі indian j
навіть індия яка так ось тут вони
кажуть і різанини вони жаху від того що
побачили
вийшла ізраїльська газета давав їм
коментар ось він тільки він вийшов
значить я ще в когось забула японцям і
японському теж телебаченню дав теж про
цьому коментар весь світ шокований та
вже політики змушені реагувати
macron вже сказав що франці розгляне
питання обмеження російського газу та
нафти і починається розмова бомбарду
паливному ти тут
вам розповів а паливному їм варгану
рашку а це кінець що це просто велика
бензоколонка і власне кажучи все
легендарний шахісти з відомий
політик гарі каспар так
прокоментував це сказав що це те
що просто ну поховає путінський режим
рідні borgata те що ж не пережити не
зможуть а що далі далі звичайно в
такої ситуації коли вже ну
євросоюз почав розглядати обмеження
поставок російського газу та нафти
виступив проти до германію ви маєте рацію ще
і цього разу ще підтримали нідерланди
Німеччина весь час теж ось
це окрема історія з Німеччини потрібно
дуже предметно працювати і друзі будемо
працюєте на цьому допомагатиме
союзники шаль з'їде Великобританію на
цього тижня не буде зустрічатися
джонсон це наш борис джонсон готує
ваенга цар борис реально наш величезний
союзник тару дуже багато робить іони в
цілому перекази і він умовлятиме
шульца і тут поміняти свою позицію США
британії австралія канада вже відмовилися
від російської нафти чи у процесі
відмови треба добивати це і тим самим ми
доб'ємо і цей режим і це розуміють дуже
багато хто в оточення путіна
відомий також систем позиціонер гони
гудків, у якого ще залишилися контакти
в оточення путіна розповідає що той
у повністю неосудному стані
істерики йому бояться приходити
розповідати погані новини
тому він живе у світі і вони напевно
ще з-під києва не пішли скоро візьму
які взагалі вони скрізь перемагають але ми з
вами знаємо що це не так і йому доведеться
з цим зіткнутися ось що з каже
гудків зараз така обстановка і вона
була тату рік до початку війни будь-кому
гінцю, який повідомив не хорошу новину
могли зарядити варварство свинцем
тому ось все те, що відбувається навколо
путіна з пультом це виключно
власне якщо путін не хоче
сприймати цим інформацію якщо він
дратується і всім цим істерить і так
далі загрожує всякими автомобілями але теж
йому буде так добре у мене багато було
людей які були вхожі у путіну і ось
наприклад одна там людина яка була
дуже близький і смак зручний як здавався
на критично налаштовані я йому streams
просто але скажи будь ласка теж би вашу
путіним буває регулярно, а чому ти мені
можеш пояснити що ось той вони зробили
ні не так це не так це не так і
взагалі все загалом доведеться сьогодні не так
як він вважає про що був до кожної війни
ангар ти знаєш гена вибач мене
будь ласка це собі дорожче я гордий це
пробував справ але виходило так що я там
а всі інші б'ють йому з ранку до
ночі поділ і коли я йому починаю
щось говорити він починає там два
вакамі означає
рухати він починає хапати трубки
починає кидати ручки і так далі тому
подібне я йду все повертається на
круги своя всією миють або його цю
strike звичайно але якщо що далі буде
заперечувати насправді далі ось так
вести війну то я думав що не далекий той
момент коли його прийдуть у цьому бункері
вже ті хто ось просто веде остаточно
у прірву тому друзі ось така
ситуація я думаю що на наших очах ми
побачимо розвал це бензоколонки та повне
загнивання спочатку і розвал і там
правильно говорить і гарі каспарів про
повному технічному боргу який має
бути але це люди справою техніка вони
тільки можуть килими чайнику у красти не
ганятися за курками все це шукайте собі
цьому
у своїх виходить із пудра ну і сидіти нам
ліктями їх чи чіп і ховатися ковдрою
які вони дивилися в україні ви самі
взагалі нічого на що не здатні тому
думаю що її загнивання буде на наших
очах відбудеться швидко і розвал цієї
імперії зла друзі тримаємо лад
підписуйтесь на канал, щоб нічого не
пропустити і ділитеся цим відео по
скриптам забув сказати лишав бориса
джонсона та британія допомагає Україні
бретер корабельними ракетами гарпун це
дуже треба щоб ось ці ось російська
військовий корабель йшов туди кудись йому
належить не намагався ну там наблизитися
до 10 та до речі друзі вчора після
обстрілів ранкових одеси наші славні з
броні сил україни покарали таку людину
і пароплав адмірал есен так от ну
людина давно померла а пароплаву тобто
фрегату новому російському фрегат
вмирали з вчора стало дуже погано
дякую за це богу морів так що не
тільки
британськими протикорабельними ракетами
ми будемо живі друзі ми і самі богово але
кінцевий британські нам не завадять